Rally Bike.
Racers, start your engines.
And welcome to NEStalgia, a chronological exploration of every NES game released in North America.
I'm Mike.
I'm Sean.
And I'm Joe.
You sound a lot more like into it this episode, Mike.
I'm so into it.
Cause unlike Rally Bike, I think my engines actually going to start.
The manual for this game, forget all the extra pages.
You know what I'm talking about, right?
The blank page on the opposite side of the table of contents, the whole like copyright stuff,
all the like little notes and everything.
Those pages don't count.
If you count just the pages with information pertaining to the actual game, it is a five-page manual.
And one of those is a picture book page.
That tracks.
I actually didn't look at the manual for this game.
I'm surprised you did.
I didn't either. And I, I thought you were about to say that it was like, it's like a 200 page.
Cause you recently talked about a manual like that.
I was like, there's no way that could have possibly been this game.
I had to do that because I just had to think that there was something else like, oh, maybe
if I keep playing, like something else happens, but it's just as easy to explain in a manual
as it will be for our episode of Rally Bike.
Yeah. I mean, it takes five seconds to learn, but a lifetime to master.
That was last week's episode.
Oh, right. Which one is this?
Rally Bike.
Yeah. Okay.
Top down motorcycle racing game where players race, you know, other motorcycle, other motorcycles,
just basically trying to complete the course.
I suppose is like one of the main feats.
But assuming that you could do that, you also have to get a certain rank placement, you know,
in order to advance. And I don't know exactly how many racers there are.
Was it 50? Yeah.
There's like 50 racers and you have to like, at least in the beginning, you have to get
to like 25th place.
So it's not like, it's not a fair race by any means.
It's not one of those races where everybody starts together.
Yeah. It's not even, it's not even Mario Kart style where like, yeah, you all take off together,
but there's one guy, you know, it's funny.
I'm calling that Mario Kart style when that's just like every style of actual real life racing.
But like essentially people started like an hour ago and now you, it's up to you to catch
them. Do you remember, did any of you guys play Ridge Racer back in the day?
Ridge Racer is a gap for me.
So in Ridge Racer, and this is something that I always disliked about Ridge Racer.
It plays like this game where you, you end up, it actually does start you all off at the
beginning of, of the race.
And then, uh, it, it, the whole like positioning stretches out so that you over the course of
the race have to like, they all get evenly spaced out and you have to go and catch up to
everybody. It's not like a real racing game.
So there's like an initial rubber band effect.
Yeah. It's like, Oh, we want you to still be overtaking people.
Even if you are, uh, you, you're playing the optimal, you're, you're, you're riding the
optimal line. You'll still be overtaking people near the end of the race.
It's strange.
Would you believe that that is how every race in Gran Turismo seven goes?
No. The latest entry in Gran Turismo.
I thought that that's what the, that's that, what they didn't want.
Right. There's no, there's no qualifying lap.
There's no like, you know, uh, figure out your placement on the grid.
You always start from, from the back and just have to catch every, overtake every single
AI computer.
That's crazy. Really?
Yeah. I thought their whole thing was like, you know, realism.
Realism. Right. It's actually nuts.
Cause of course online in the, in the online mode, you do do a qualifying lap.
So, Oh, the technology is there.
They just don't want to do it for the base game.
It'd be funny if in an online mode, like half the people are just like the people who are
way ahead to begin with.
But this is like, this is an extreme, right?
Like, like you start in 50th place and the guy in first might be like halfway across the
map. Yeah. Now are these people, I mean, I'm these people like, are these, they're not actually
people. Yeah.
There's someone else online playing against me.
No, they would like, you know, there's, I'm assuming there's just like, Oh, you've gotten
to this point. Let's just put in.
It's not like, Oh, this, this guy in front starts halfway across the race.
No. Yes. It's just like you get to a certain point.
They're like, all right, throw another guy.
There is a steady trickle of, of other racers to overtake across the entire length of the
race. Um, yeah, no matter what, which, which is one of the things that makes this racing game
as a racing game have no tension.
Um, and, and sorry to get into like qualitative stuff immediately, but like also just like
the overall speed of the game kind of attributes to that.
It's very slow for a racer.
Right. Yeah.
But then also just thinking about like what this game is now, like it, you could probably
solve this game.
Right. Hmm.
Like it's just exact inputs that like, there's never, you never have to really react to anything.
It's, I don't know if it's the same, if it's always like the same arrangement of other
races you have to take.
So maybe not solvable like that.
And where the gas is and stuff like that.
Yeah. Like, you know, you're using fuel and everything like, like, okay.
So there is, there are like racing elements to it.
Right. There's a, there's a tune up shop where like, yes, it's really nothing.
Um, nothing too intricate.
Right. You can either have, um, a two cycle engine or a four cycle engine.
And even though they both go the same speed, it's just one is, um, is like, uh, better on,
it goes faster on straight runs.
And the other one is like, if you need to turn, it does better.
Not acceleration.
Yeah. Yes, exactly.
Uh, and then the other thing is tires, but like, yeah, so there are raising opponents,
but actually the weirdest part of this, and you know, you could say that this might apply
to other racing is by truly think it belongs here is like, this game is less a racing game
and less even like vehicular combat game where it is just like tracing a line from one end
of the screen to the other.
Like all you're doing essentially is just, you're almost doing like a shmup with no shooting.
You're just dodging giant boulders and, um, and whatever, you know, I'm, I'm, I'm on the
desert stage right now, but like whatever it is on your screen, like whatever stage you're
currently on, it's just obstacles in the way.
There's other racers that you just have to kind of like avoid occasionally like a car will,
you know, try to like run you over something or a train will try to come out of nowhere.
But like, ultimately you're just like, just dodging.
You're not racing really.
Yeah. There's no like strategy to your vehicle.
The, the, I actually, as I was playing the game, like had this thought coalesce in my
head, which was that this game has more in common with Flappy Bird than it has with like
Forza. Like it, it's, Oh, absolutely.
Yeah. It's just a, an object avoidance game.
Like there's nothing about like, Oh, you're, am I going to be able to make this turn?
Like, no, you're, it's a drag racer.
Yeah. The only thing that like makes it feel like some other racers is like the fuel management.
Yeah. And the fact that, and I guess that's kind of now I'm like amending what I was thinking
before about like it being solvable, not that it's solvable, but I can imagine that there's
a, that there could be a, a strategy guide that tells you like when like accelerate for
this amount of time, then stop because then there'll be a gas station coming up and then
accelerate here. Don't accelerate here.
You know, just kind of telling you exactly how to manage your fuel.
And then theoretically you will win as long as you don't run into anything.
And Joe, it's interesting because the way you're making it sound, and I know you, you
know this, but like to the listener, it might sound like, Oh, like don't accelerate on these
turns or don't accelerate.
Yeah. You know, like, like when you're in this position or something, the whole game is just a straight
line. Like, you know, it's not, it's not that kind of thing.
You actually would be better off just going your max speed and just making sure that when
you see gas that you slow down enough so that you don't miss it.
Like the worst thing that can happen to you in a run is missing gas because you basically
just want to be.
It's not so much missing every, like you, you need to know when to accept the gas because
there's going to be like three or four drops and usually don't want to take the first one.
And most likely it's just like, which, which of these gas stops do I use?
Because you're going to need it eventually.
Yeah. And there were a few times where me accelerating at the max and just hoping I get to, you know,
and knowing I would probably get to a gas station soon screwed me over.
Like there is one point where, um, a truck, a giant truck like chases you and you need to
be accelerating at max acceleration.
And, uh, you know, the first time I got to that, I didn't have enough gas to do like the
double accelerate, like full acceleration and make it without the truck running me over.
So like, I would, then I realized, okay, I should have saved some, not that I could have known
that, but I should have saved some, some gas so I could like fully accelerate at this point.
And that's really the only rally aspect of this.
Like it's, it's definitely over like the, the, the textures on the ground change.
So that, okay, that's rally and okay.
You've got fuel and I guess that's, that's really it in terms of the namesake.
And I guess technically you're on a bike.
The, uh, according to the manual, at least the stop for gas, um, the reason why it sometimes
takes like a long time to fill up or whatever is apparently because five racers have to pass
you before you can, like finish the gas stop.
I didn't know it was based on that.
I wouldn't have guessed that either.
Like it wasn't something I like would have clocked.
I wouldn't have been looking at like the amount of people passing me, but it is kind of interesting
as like, you know, like a pit lane rule because it's kind of weird that they're not just like
pit lanes and that they are just like gas icons anywhere on the screen.
Like that would have actually been something to like keep an eye out for, right.
Is to like, you know, look for signage over on the left or right side of the screen being
like, you know, pit, pit lane coming up or whatever and trying to like slow down and get
in there. But, but instead it's just like an actual icon of a gas canister and you just have to like ride
over it. This is like the way you're describing this is kind of like the worst possible way to
do this because if you're, if you want to make this a skill based game, you would, you
might think like, oh, you want to take it when you think you've got a pretty good lead on
like, let's even keep it to the last five racers.
Like you think that you'll be able to fill up most of the way before even like two or
three racers overtake you.
So it, it's more of a strategic decision of when you take your gas, but no, it's just
built in, uh, built in five left to pass.
I think that's more so because it doesn't even know where these other racers are because
it's not tracking them once they leave the screen.
I think, yeah, it's like they're, they're like doubling down though on the, on the like
idea that the game design is all artificial or like the, you know, like the game theory
in this is all artificial where it's like, yeah, all these racers in front of you, like
we're just putting them there when, you know, when it feels right.
Like they're not actually, you know, there's no code that tells you how far ahead anything
is. And the same thing with like, okay, if you want to take, if you want to take a, you
know, get gas, you get like a time penalty, but it's really not a time penalty.
It's an exactly five places penalty.
It's crazy. Considering then that the game is mostly about object dodging.
Uh, and there are, it should be mentioned, you know, moments where, uh, you know, and they
are brief moments in the game where you do need to also jump, uh, over things as that specifically
happens in like the level with the docks where you have to jump over.
Uh, otherwise you'll just fall into the pit.
Uh, you know, how good then are the, forget the static obstacles.
They're present in every level.
How interesting is the dynamic stuff?
Like are the racers, uh, you know, like the, the, the enemy racers, are they challenging
you? Are they trying to like make you wipe out?
Are the, uh, like we were talking about cars and trains, uh, that aren't part of the
race, but are part of the environment.
Are they interesting or are they just like littered?
Uh, they, they, they at least like try and block you, but not very hard.
They don't try very hard.
Like they'll move over like one sprites worth to try and get in your way.
So you like, they're either kind of choking you off if you're in a tight corridor or, uh,
like just, just enough to kind of throw you off and maybe even put you into like an oil slick.
So it, it's not, it's not completely mindless, but there isn't, there isn't too much going
on here. In fact, if you were to stop at a gas station, like they will just collide behind you in certain
circumstances and you have to wait for more, uh, uh, more vehicles to pass you and waste
even more of your time.
Yeah. I think that, I think that there are some other obstacles other than the other racers that
are, that are better than the other racers.
There's like swerving cars and there's that truck that I mentioned, which was an annoyance
to me, but, but actually, you know, I do think was like a pretty cool little, um, obstacle
because it wasn't just like avoid this.
It's like get in front of this.
Okay. Now it's chasing you, you know, stay ahead of it.
Um, but, uh, you know, nothing where it both, it never felt too hard because there are like,
these obstacles are really like well-placed.
It often felt hard because it's hard to avoid the obstacles because the movement is really
touchy to the left and right for me.
But, but so it, you know, it's kind of like hard to gauge.
And the most crushing part of the game
isn't the climb from whatever,
it goes even higher in the later stages,
but it isn't the climb from rank 50 to rank one.
It's really what happens when you crash.
Yeah, it brings you back to the beginning.
The beginning, right?
Like now I've seen in earlier games
where you crash on a motorcycle
and you just get right back up and lose some time
and obviously people are passing you.
Or the Koopa in the cloud comes and grabs you
and then moves you over.
Right, right.
He's not a Koopa. Whatever, he looks like a Koopa.
He's part of Koopa's army.
Anyway. Yeah, what's the politics in Mario Kart like?
Not the individual character's political beliefs,
but just like...
The identity politics of the Koopa army.
Like why is Bowser at the race?
Yeah, I mean there's got to be some tensions there, right?
Has to be.
Unless we subscribe to the idea
that it's always a stage play.
Yeah. Right?
Like every single game.
Or is this like during the era of peace?
No, this is the Pax Bowsera.
And this is the only way that they solve disputes.
Right, we just haven't seen the game from Nintendo yet
where they solve.
Like where Mario and Bowser like shake hands
and say like it's all good again
and then that's where...
Canonically, that is where like Mario Kart, Mario Party,
Mario versus NBA Street Volume 3,
like that's where all that stuff happens.
Is there never any like little silly cut scene
at the beginning of a Mario Kart that's like,
hey, this is why we're racing?
Nope. CTR.
CTR all the way.
Has that? It has that.
Better game. Well, it is a better game, yeah.
It's got to be. Because all games need good plots
of which this game has zero.
Yeah, I would have liked like why am I racing?
Like... Yeah, right.
Am I trying to impress a girl?
Is it the only way that I can make money
because I never learned how to read?
Is it just like my family?
Are you saving a princess or something?
Yeah, maybe that.
I need some motivation.
This needed like...
This needed some kind of endorsement behind it.
You know, if you're not going to have a story,
at least have like the guy who's driving the motorcycle
be someone you care about,
like Freddy Spencer.
Or Evel Knievel.
Evel Knievel would have been interesting as well.
Freddy Spencer, I don't know who he is,
but he was the...
You just Googled him?
The dominant 80s Grand Prix motorcycle racer of the time.
So, get him. Yeah.
Sounds like you do know who he is.
Well, I looked it up.
I know. Because we have the internet these days, Joe.
I don't. Freddy Spencer's rally bike?
That sounds awesome.
It does. Freddy Spencer's rally bike just makes it feel like a more complete game.
And all you have to do is,
I think it was, you know,
kind of like the Magic Johnson basketball game.
Like, between each race,
just show like a mugshot of Freddy Jackson.
Or Freddy Johnson. Freddy Spencer.
Joe Freddy Jackson. Who's going to know?
Magic Spencer. Whatever.
Just put that there.
And you've got... The game is new and improved.
Because I guess like,
looking at it,
otherwise, right?
Like, when I think about the game,
it's not that it's buggy,
or that it...
I'm not even saying it wasn't fun, right?
Like, oh, you know, like, oh, I've got to keep talking about this game.
But like, I just don't have anything else to say.
Like, you know,
what am I going to do?
I start talking about the helicopters?
Like, there's really no reason.
We don't just say things to say them.
We kind of do.
But, you know, that's our job.
What do you want to just say then right now?
Doesn't have to be about the game.
Just, you know, I've been struggling to figure out
what I want to say this whole episode.
I guess what I want to say is
I just appreciate you guys.
Okay. I thought instead you were going to maybe talk about
how they abbreviate miles per hour
as just miles,
like miles slash H.
Mile over hour. I did not realize this.
Mile over H, though. If only there really was
an existing abbreviation for that.
Right. Why couldn't they just put MPH there?
Instead, mile divided by H?
You guys didn't know that MPH,
MPH, MPH was
copywritten by Chevrolet
at the time, I think.
Well, pretty soon there will be,
once it goes into public domain,
there will be like a horror movie
about MPH.
I'd like to use
a few more minutes of this
to get back to Mario Kart
because I had the opportunity
to play Mario Kart Arcade GP2.
Wow, I've never heard of that.
Yeah. It's the second arcade version
of Mario Kart. And, you know,
so many creative ideas there.
Is this a modern game
or is this like a...
It's a modern game, yeah. Okay.
It's a modern game.
It's basically like,
you know, one of those Daytona-style cabinets
where you sit in a car
and you have, you know,
the pedals and the brakes
and a steering wheel.
And there's other ideas
like Mario Kart related ideas
that aren't in the main game.
Specifically, like, that you can team up
with another person
who's also playing
in the same arcade as you
or you can have different kinds
of like types of power-ups to use
and there's like a dedicated
power-up button that you hit.
But most importantly,
and I need you to know this is the most important thing,
is that right before the race begins,
you have the opportunity
to take a really funny picture
of yourself wearing like
the hat or skin
of the Mario character you chose.
And it's really important
that you smile in that photo.
Why? Everybody's gonna see it.
Everybody meaning who?
Like, is this an online game?
Uh, no. It's only...
So there's eight. There's usually like...
I think there's usually four actually.
There might be as many as eight,
but there's usually four
Mario Kart arcade cabinets.
What arcade did you play this at?
I played this at the Cidercade
in, uh,
no, Austin, Texas.
Oh, okay. Got it.
Yep. Which is running a really weird promotion
that I can talk about now,
but it won't be active by the time anybody hears this episode.
They're running a promotion right now
where if you go up to the entrance
where you're supposed to buy
your ticket for admission
and show them, uh,
the, you know, the universal sign for peace,
but also the sign for scissors
in rock, paper, scissors.
Okay. They know that you are challenging them
to a game of rock, paper, scissors,
and if you win,
you get to go in for free.
The, this,
this arcade is willing to bet
33% chance
that they're gonna
just give you free access.
They're actually saying,
so it's, it's best two out of three,
and they're saying 50% of the time
they win 100% of the time.
Wait, so does that mean
that they just always choose rock
and then they, you have to pay?
Right? Yeah, right? Like, what do they know
about the two out of three strategy?
Like, what, do I have to get a book on this?
I did recently, um, I did recently see a,
a little video about, like,
the statistics of what people
normally pick when they lose
versus when they win,
and based on those statistics,
like, I don't remember what it was exactly,
but, like, if you lose,
then you should go forward
in the rock, paper, scissors order,
and if you win, you should go backwards.
That could be rock, paper, scissors.
Oh. That's, like, the way you say it,
so if you chose rock,
you should go to paper next.
I, now that could, I, I might have that backwards,
but, like, it's something like that,
and it gives you,
it boosts your odds as long as the other person
doesn't know about this.
This is why I've ridden
the next 100 rock,
paper, scissors throws
that I will throw down
on a piece of paper.
Smart. And I just cross them out
as I go along.
There's also a power-up
where you get little
dirt bike people next to you.
Yeah, what's up with those little dirt bike people?
It's just like a,
you know, you can use them to,
to hurt people.
The, the little shmup guys.
Yeah. Did Evil Knievel
have little people with him?
I, well, I think, I don't know if that's,
like, the correct term.
That's true. Um,
in the game, they are actually just
smaller versions of people,
though, right? Like, that's,
yeah, like, smaller versions of your racer
are smaller bikes.
instead of, yeah, as, like,
on a, like, but their bodies are smaller,
too. I mean,
they're, yeah, they're younger.
Okay. They're,
like, 16. Cool.
And they're riding, How old is your main guy?
Like, 27.
I did say that in the manual.
Any lifts? He's exactly 27.
Yeah. They actually use the word
exactly 27.
I guess they're implying that he's racing.
That was one word. Again,
like, this whole game
takes place on his birthday.
Rally bike. He's exactly 27.
Is this going to be
our most popular episode?
That's the back of the box.
What else was on the back of the box?
It's just, he's a,
he's exactly 27 years old.
And his name is Rally Bike,
I guess. Also,
why is there a parking lot
in the middle
of, like, 6th Avenue?
Sorry, there's a New York City,
there's a New York City map
in this game.
no, they're all different. Yeah,
they're all different parts of this.
I guess, like, there is a story.
It's just, like, one of those Dark Souls stories
where you have to, like, piece it together.
Yeah, you gotta ring a bell.
You gotta, like, use the clues of the environment
to, like, tell the story.
And then, like, you end up,
you're going down an avenue
and it turns into,
like, a Cabela's parking lot
and people are still racing
through it, but it just went,
it went directly from,
like, a full traffic avenue
to, like,
a giant parking lot.
So it's kind of dreamlike.
Like, this might be, like, a game that happens in a dream.
I don't know. And then you're down,
you're going on the Roosevelt Parkway,
too. I'm looking at the rest of the back of the box
and I'm, it's not sure if it's,
like, the back of the box for a video game
or for a defensive driving,
like, VHS tape.
Maneuver past obstacles.
Score extra bonus points.
Keep off the curbs.
Watch out for cars.
Stay pumped up.
Blow off your competitors.
Conquer the ramps.
And above all else,
wear your helmets and don't drink and drive.
What is happening? It says don't drink and drive on there?
It literally says don't drink and drive
on separate text,
like, new font,
new color, everything.
Wow. Maybe the whole game was,
like, made to be just,
like, a PSA. Like,
the game itself is the Trojan horse.
Yeah, but you wouldn't know
unless you read the back of the box.
Yeah, that's true. You don't even need to play the game.
Which means that you would only get their mission
if you owned a complete in box,
complete in box copy of RallyBite.
Early DRM. Yep.
What does it go for? Take your guesses.
$23. $21.5.
Complete in box?
$21.5.
I'm only saying $23 because of,
uh, because of Pipe Dream,
but I'll say, I'll say $45.
$80. That's bullshit.
I don't think I'd be paying $80.
But I will put down my vote
in the Essential Games list.
RallyBike's just another one of
those video games.
What do you mean those video games?
I mean the kind of games
where you play them
and you record them on this podcast
and then you forget about them.
You, uh, you just kind of like
acknowledge that it happened
and you're not really sure
why you didn't like it,
but you know you didn't like it.
And I know I didn't like it.
I know I didn't like it
because I,
I kind of like
just didn't even,
like I played the game
and I, I kind of like was looking
at the notes page
for like the episode
and I was like, guess I could just write about
the features of the game.
But that's kind of boring.
Like there's not a lot to like,
it's not a lot of extra flair
in this game. I feel like we've gotten past
the point in this podcast,
300 plus episodes in,
where like, we're just gonna explain
features of a video game
to our audience of guys
who mostly play these video games
already, right? Like that's not what
this is supposed to be, but Rally Bike offers
so little else to it
that that's really
all it could have been.
So instead of playing this,
maybe just next time
you see Mario Kart Arcade GP2,
you smile when your photo is taken.
Sean? There's probably some kind of
like formula,
solving for X,
that if you took
the length of the episode
and then you took
how long it took for us
to break all conceits
that we are
talking about the game,
you might come up with
some ratio or some kind of
some number on a scale
that tells you just
how little we think it's important.
And I think this probably
ranks pretty highly
or low,
depending on
how that formula works out.
in that list of games
because we really didn't
we really didn't talk about the game too much.
And I think that
that's pretty much
because it's
it's not worth your time.
I'd call this a
100% skip it.
It's it barely feels like a racer.
It has none of the
the tension that comes
with the racer. So
yeah, I guess
I'm gonna be
I'm gonna second
the fact that you
should smile for your picture
in whatever game
Mike's talking about.
Not essential.
If alright, if you take
out the fact
that the like
if I don't know
that the
these racers
are like
kind of artificially
racing you
you're not really
catching up to anyone
you gotta wait
until exactly five people
pass you when you fill out the gas
like if I'm not aware
of that I'm still
having a pretty bad
time. Then when you
add that stuff in
like I hate
this game. So this game
wasn't fun like
in the first like minute
or whatever I was like okay
it's another
one of these but then it
just got kind of worse and worse
for me. Not a fan.
Don't play this game.
Smile for your picture. I have no idea
what this says about me
but I just
I just think
right away like my
opinion of this
game it wouldn't get
on the essential games list
but my opinion of this game
would improve if you could
just shoot
something out of your motorcycle
at other motorcycles
and I don't know what that says
about me but like
just that
little thing is like
yeah that's actually just
enough to even get me a little
more excited about rally bike
but you can't shoot the other
motorcycles. I don't know
which entry
it was maybe it was
like NASCAR 98
or 97
or 99
it was a
PlayStation era
you know
simulation NASCAR game
but if you put a cheat code
in you could
have a stream
of little
spherical sprites
shoot out the front
of Dale Earnhardt
or Jeff
Gordon's car and you could
make those cars wipe out
in front of you it was pretty
awesome. I think
we should
play that instead. Was that
NASCAR 98? NASCAR 98.
Man I've got
that game
play that game
instead. It's funny
because like we're not
spoiled by
racers on the NES
we've seen some interesting
good entries
in the genre
but like racers do
really like especially
arcade racers
really take
off once we
hit 64
bits. There's just
something about like 64
bit like N64
PS1 PS2
you know like that
era of things
which is
two generations technically
like just
amazing arcade
racers in that Saturn
games a lot of good Saturn
racers. It seems
just a lot
harder to
get the feeling of
speed in
these 8-bit like pixel
era. I think that's
what we liked about Mock
Rider so much.
Yeah. Right.
Absolutely. There wasn't
anything crazy going on
behind like
under the hood with that
game. I think a lot
of times like I think like
oh well maybe if they just
actually kept track of each
racer like it'd be a lot
more fun but like you get
that in like the Super
Nintendo era with at
least like Mario Kart
and I would
and as much as I like
Mario Kart I don't think
that the original is
my favorite
so I
don't know I agree
it takes a
while for for actual
racing games
to feel great.
Yeah other than OutRun
which I'm not
sure if that's like really
an arcade
racer. Yeah they're
not really racing anybody
on that. Yeah it's
more like just an arcade
game. It's a speed
simulator. The